the staging of breast cancer refers to
the extent of the disease the cancer
stage is based on several factors
including the size of the tumor if any
lymph nodes are involved if the cancer
is invasive or non-invasive and if the
cancer has spread to areas beyond the
breast
stage zero is considered a non invasive
breast cancer in this stage there is no
evidence that the cancer cells have
spread into neighboring breast tissue
beyond the duck or lobule
Stage one is considered an early stage
of invasive breast cancer when measured
the tumor is no more than 2 centimeters
in diameter and there is no evidence
that the cancer cells have spread beyond
the breast
Stage two is divided into subcategories
of 2a and 2b stage 2a is invasive breast
cancer where the tumor is either a
maximum of 2 centimeters in diameter and
has spread to the lymph nodes under the
arm or the tumor is between 2 and 5
centimeters in diameter but has not
spread to any lymph nodes
stage 2b is a little different and that
the tumor is either between two and five
centimeters and has spread to underarm
lymph nodes or the tumor is larger than
five centimeters but has not spread to
the underarm lymph nodes
Stage three is considered a locally
advanced cancer and it is also divided
into subcategories of 3a 3b and 3c
there are two main scenarios that can
occur with stage 3 a breast cancer one
where the tumor is no larger than 5
centimeters in diameter but it has
spread to underarm lymph nodes that are
growing into each other forming clumps
the cancer may also have spread to the
lymph nodes near the breastbone
the second scenario for stage 3a is very
similar with the exception that the
tumour is larger than five centimeters
in diameter and that the underarm lymph
nodes are not adhered to one another or
other tissues
unlike the other stages in stage 3b the
tumor may be any size and has spread
into the skin of the breast or chest
wall this stage may also include lumps
in the skin of the breast or swelling of
the breasts
in stage 3c the tumor may also be of any
size but it is also spread to lymph node
areas above or below the clavicle the
chest wall and/or the skin of the breast
Stage four is considered distant
metastatic cancer meaning the cancer has
spread to other organs and parts of the
body